bon bah ils sont toujours pas revenus en
fait donc je vous ai trouvé un autre
épisode d'écorce de recherche toujours
dans la série voir l'invisible et ben
je vous laisse regarder
et puis bonnes vacances
Toutes nos salutations chers spectatrices
et spectateurs.
Vous ne venez pas de voir le motif de la
prochaine robe Pierre Cardin, vous savez
ce jeune créateur en vogue.
Non, ceci est le
résultat d'une observation réalisée
à l'aide d'un microscope
mais pas n'importe lequel..
Célébrons l'avènement du microscope métallographique.
Les scientifiques du laboratoire de
magnétisme et physique du solide
ici même à meudon bellevue ont développé un nouveau dispositif d'observation
dynamique et voici le type de films
qu'ils obtiennent :
Hypnotisant n'est ce pas ? Ce n'est
pas sans rappeler les effets surprenants
des paradis artificiels décrits par
Charles Baudelaire, mais en réalité ces
images poétiques nous donnent à voir les
changements qui ont lieu à l'intérieur
d'un cristal  soumis un champ magnétique.
Attention ce que j'entends ici par cristal
n'est pas celui des flûtes de
champagne que la maîtresse de maison
et peut-être un jour le maître de maison
range au fond du vaisselier..
Non, il s'agit ici d'un cristal métallique.
En effet à température ambiante
la plupart des métaux comme le fer forment
des cristaux c'est à dire des solides
dont les atomes sont agencés de façon
régulière. Anecdote cocasse : les
verres en cristal ne sont justement pas
constitué de cristaux !
Les recherches réalisées par les scientifiques
de Meudon-Bellevue ont pour but d'observer les
phénomènes microscopiques menant
à l'aimantation d'un métal.
L'observation  est réalisée sur des cristaux de fer, de
nickel,  de cobalt
ou d'un oxyde de fer et de plomb.
L'échantillon est
préalablement préparé.
Sur sa surface parfaitement polie,
les chercheurs déposent un liquide dans
lequel baignent de très fines particules
magnétiques.
C'est ce que l'on appelle un ferrofluide.
Une fois l'échantillon positionné dans le microscope
une bobine est placée autour pour générer
un champ magnétique variable.
Cela reviendrait à approcher de l'échantillon
un aimant plus ou moins fort, orienté
dans un sens puis dans l'autre.
Que se passe-t-il à ce stade ?
l'échantillon de cristal métallique est
constitué de petits éléments de volume
invisibles à l'oeil nu,
appelés domaines magnétiques. C'est
l'évolution de ces domaines en présence
d'un champ magnétique que les
scientifiques étudient.
Autrement dit comment les échantillons s'aimantent-ils ?
Incroyable : en surface du cristal
certains de ces petits domaines vont
attirer les fines particules du ferrofluide
dans lequel baigne l'échantillon.
Ses fines particules étant noires,
elles dessinent alors des motifs sinueux dans
l'objectif du microscope.
les motifs qui  se dessinent dans les ferrofluides
révèlent donc les modifications internes
du cristal soumis au champ magnétique,
aussi clairement que si l'on soupoudrait
l'homme invisible de farine.
Cette étude permet donc aux
scientifiques de mieux comprendre le
processus d'aimantation et contribue
à une meilleure connaissance de ces
matériaux de plus en plus utilisés dans
notre monde moderne.
Et en cette veille des jeux olympiques
de Tokyo nous pouvons désormais rêver
de voyager jusqu'au Japon dans des
transports à sustentation magnétique.
Et pourquoi pas imaginer de planer sur une
planche à roulettes en lévitation.
Ainsi le microscope métallographique
nous a rendus visibles les effets
surprenants de l'électromagnétisme...
une science bigrement attirante.
Abonnez vous, nom de Zeus !